hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
ist wahrscheinlich schon im titel
eingeblendet wir spielen heute das
übelste spiel also ja was ist das
übelste spiel mia willkommen zum
übelsten handyspiele war mit mir als
hauptfigur diese katze ist die
hauptfigur von diesem spiel fangen wir
gleich an indem wir ein paar
fürchterliche mini games zocken jetzt
lege ich auf weiter und ihr seht schon
das hier ist das spiel nämlich ist es
dass grumpy cats spiel kennt vielleicht
die grumpy cat aus diesen neun games
es ist einfach irgend eine katze die
halt irgendwie wirklich echt ist aber
total bescheuert guckt und von der wurde
jetzt ein spiel gemacht wir klicken
einfach mal unten auf play ihr seht
schon einen punktestandes 0 und jetzt
muss ich die nadeln hier aus dem dings
rausziehen hat das geschafft und jetzt
ist mein punkte schon 10 o gott es geht
die ganze zeit weiter fangen die vögel
okay hier ist ein vogel da sind vögel da
da dam da hat die katze vogel gefangen
punkte stand es 30 und ich habe ein plus
[Applaus]
game findet den goldfisch meine damen
und herren kann es sein dass dieses
spiel die ganze zeit dauernd weitergeht
jetzt muss ich wieder die nadeln hier
aus diesem typen rausziehen so jetzt ist
die katze da wieder glücklich mein
punktestand erhöht sich auf 50 schneller
jetzt wird ja alles schneller oder wie
man die vögel da sind vögel hier ja okay
jetzt haben wir die katze punktestand 70
was für goldfisch finden herz verloren
e10 wieder die nadeln raus und es werden
auch immer mehr nato mein gott wie soll
man das irgendwie schaffen alter das
macht fun schade dass du so schlecht
bist okay halt auch
dieses spiel ist darauf aufgebaut dass
man verschiedene minigames auf zeit
spielt und die werden nach und nach
immer die gleichen seien allerdings
immer mit zum beispiel mehr nadeln
rausziehen und da muss man das schneller
machen und so ich versuchs doch mal
ich versuche es noch mal aber erst mal
versuche ich hier im preis zu gewinnen
und zwar habe ich die gelbe kugel und in
der gelben kugel befindet sie
eine kratzende glombik at
wow
gefällt dir grumpy keltern übel spiel
also bisher gefällt mir noch nicht weil
ich nicht so gut bei gott keine mail an
die schreiben hat spaß gemacht ich habe
dir doch gesagt dass es fürchterlich ist
jedes mal wenn du einen neuen charaktere
frei spielt bekommst du ein neues mini
game ich mag es nicht an einem ort zu
bleiben also ziemlich auf dem bildschirm
herum probiert einfach mal aus das heißt
ich nehmen sie jetzt sie beispielsweise
mal hier unten hin dass ein schönes
fleckchen lasst uns ein foto was ihr
foto machen mit klick ich hier unten
drauf und kann jetzt
wow man sieht die grumpy cat dahinter ja
richtig gut la super lover noch weiter
wir machen weiterhin mit dem mini games
m ich muss so platzer toll gelaufen mir
bin wieder richtig gut eure die box soll
das habe ich geschafft
jetzt ist mein punktestand auf 10 das
nächste mini spiel so so so so so da mal
den fisch diesmal sogar gefunden jetzt
wird das ganze schneller das heißt ich
fange hier kurz den punkt sondern mit
dem punkt gefangen und der punktestand
erhöht sich auf 30 wir bekommen plus 5
münzen die die vögel fangen da ist einer
hier ist eine hier soll da haben wir die
vögel gefangen und der punktestand er
wird sich auf 40 nadeln wieder aus dem
komischen pelster quantität rausziehen
unser punkte scheinen sich auf 50 jetzt
wird das ganze wiederum wieder schneller
und ich muss jetzt wieder diesen
komischen art man wann immer diese
scheiss ausweichen
[Musik]
clip ansehen dieses spiel macht also
damit gewinnen dass man süchtig wird und
sich dann solche werbe videos von
irgendwelchen komischen drachen anschaut
und damit man weiter spielen kann bin
ich aber an sich gut weil es den leuten
freigestellt ist ob sie warten oder sich
eine werbung anschauen das ganze wird
jetzt wieder schneller das heißt hier
irgendwie den punkt kommt hyundai wada
ist der punkt so und jetzt haben die
punkte schon auf 70 wir bekommen als
schenk diesmal acht münzen die nadeln
rausziehen oh mein gott mein gott warum
ist es denn so schwer meine fresse das
macht fun schnauze ist in ordnung okay
ich ziehe die gramm wiegt jetzt einfach
mal hier hinten hinzu der
höchstpunktzahl und ich weiß allerdings
nicht was was ich jetzt irgendwie was
ich hier irgendwie das ich
[Musik]
kann ich dir nur mini spiele spielen
es gibt noch grumpy wood und garten und
keine ahnung was sie gehen mal wieder zu
den minispielen und ich fange mal wieder
so ein paar vögel ein jetzt finden wir
mal alle zusammen den goldfisch hier
soll da haben wir den goldfisch gefunden
und das ganze wird schneller das heißt
ich werde jetzt diesmal wirklich
schaffen hier passend auszuweichen leute
so alter ich habe es geschafft zum
ersten euch das ausweichen geschafft
nadeln rausziehen es auch noch recht wie
sie bei der geschwindigkeit gerade also
da kann sich die krankheit auch freunde
50 punkte stand so hoch und die box
geschossen wir haben 60 punkte stand
hier kommen vögel hoch da haben wir die
vögel und wir haben einen siebziger
punktestand das heißt wir bekommen +8
münzen von dem wir uns dann später
irgendein geschenk holen können kommen
hier zum goldfisch kurz vor knapp
wir haben jetzt schon unseren high score
erreicht das heißt wir haben schon 90
das ist schon besser als unser highscore
das war glaube ich 80 soll die nadel
habe ich jetzt auch alle geschafft
rauszuziehen die box habe ich leider
verfehlt deswegen bekomme ich jetzt ein
herz abgezogen hier aber bürgel krieg
ich die hintertür das ganze wird wieder
schneller ich muss ausweichen oh mein
gott ok ok ich es geschafft mit dem
ausweichen alter da warum bin ich dann
auf einmal so gut ab zum goldfisch se
schon leute das ist dass wir zum
verhängnis ich habe es gesagt habe es
gesagt so herz verloren nadeln
rausziehen oh mein gott ist das allemal
the fucking schnell hier alles es fehlt
noch mal schneller und ich muss
irgendwie diesen blöden punkt fahren da
haben wir den proben wir haben einen
punkt rückstand verloren
[Musik]
er bittet ansehen ich werde mir dieses
spiel nicht runterladen es wird wieder
schneller meine damen und herren alter
wie soll ich das denn irgendwie
hinkriegen wenn das noch schneller wird
aber die vögel haben hingekriegt ich
will nur dieses nächste paket da
irgendwie habe ich mein gott ok die
nadel aber auch aus bekommen ist
frustrierend was gefällt mir
dieses scheiß grumpy kat wir haben einen
neuen bestwert und 280 wir erhalten
jetzt münzen dadurch dass auch gott
warum muss ich mir ein ständiger
bewerbung angucken ja ich weiß ich hab
selber drauf geprägte münzen zu erhalten
danke an meine damen und herren vikings
lade ich mir auch nicht runter aber wir
können jetzt erst mal das geschenke
auspacken haben 98 münzen das als
insgesamt 240 wir gewinnen jetzt mal
einen preis und zwar nehmen wir diesmal
wieder die gelbe kugel meine damen und
herren und ich hoffe dass er jetzt etwas
anderes drin sein wird nämlich eine
kochende grumpy kat
ok
ängstigt sie mal noch eine kugel und
zwar liefern die blaue hier hinten und
in der blauen befindet wie talk was ist
als den eimer menschen haben wir vorne
stehen und hier vorne haben wir den
kochen umgekehrt also ich weiss nicht
passt jetzt der der das ziel des spiels
ist was das soll und ob es noch
irgendwie mehr gibt aber ich glaube pro
freigeschaltete personen gibt es ein
neues minispiel das hier ist auch schon
das erste neue minispiele und zwar
müssen wir einfach das essen fangen was
hier oben runter geworfen wird das ist
bisher noch recht isi habe ich doch wenn
es nachher schwerer wird dann wird das
auch relativ schwere jetzt müssen wir
hier das drauf legen was die haben
wollte nämlich tomaten und pitz die
minispiele sind nice eigentlich hier
schön ausweichen diesem komischen
baumstümpfen und dann sind wir jeden
moment oben und haben auch das minispiel
hier geschafft ich meine die ersten paar
mini spiele bei dem bei dem
schnelligkeit level relativ easy aber
jetzt wird hier auch schon schön bin ich
schlecht vögel habe ich gefangen das
heißt ich bekomme den punktestand wieder
erhöht den punkt haben wir hier auch
direkt wieder gefangen aber wirklich
dass mit diesem inbox abfeuern und so
das ist wenn schnell es ist unfassbar
ausweichen ausweichen ausweichen und ich
bin oben am baum angekommen bin bei 70
bekomme ich jetzt bloß acht münzen das
ganze wird wieder schneller meine damen
und herren das heißt jetzt essen fangen
wir schnell herum ein gott der mich
verarschen
wie schnell soll das denn noch werden er
will dass das und tomaten
[Musik]
ich wusste es ich schaue mir wieder eine
werbung an teure die katze die box da
haben wir es geschafft meine damen und
herren soll 90 punkte wir sind wieder
schneller am start das heißt hier zack
zack zack zack zack wir haben den
goldfisch kurz vor knapp erreicht
drücken um auszuweichen alter ohne spaß
das hier ist das aller schwierigste
finde ich aber es war zum glück noch
relativ hoher zügel fangen ist das
leichteste meiner mal
[Musik]
vögel fangen ist also das leichteste
glückwunsch du hast ein neues areal frei
gespielt das heißt ich kann jetzt auf
die welt klicken und serie zu
[Musik]
alter okay dass das ist cool ich muss
die drähte miteinander verbinden what
the [ __ ] was geht denn ja ab ich weiß
gar nicht worum es geht finde grumpy kat
die sitzt die ist hier oben links ist
die wir haben punktestand von 20 jetzt
geht's schneller säubere den teller das
heißt hier alles ein versorger machen
und sagt der celler ist sauber einen
punktestand von 40 wieder die drähte
hier miteinander verbinden
diese mini spiele machen echt mehr spaß
wir haben 80 als punktestand das ganze
wird wieder schneller und ich muss
wieder den teller seilbahn oh mein gott
hella donna ist das schwierigste finde
ich 90er punktestand die linien
miteinander verbinden tower mein gott
das war richtig eng gerade geschenkt
sind diesmal zehn münzen jetzt
wiederholen wo und wir sind wieder am
tanzen alle wir haben punktestand von
130 teller säubern ist das übels
beschissene irgendwann vertraglich noch
keller 750er punktestand grumpy cap
befindet sehe ich da nein ich habe sie
doch gerade angelegt
ja ich gucke mir noch eine werbung an
das ganze wird wieder schneller und ich
muss natürlich den teller säubern alter
er ich wusste es das direkt diese scheiß
tellerwäscher aufgabe wieder kamen sie
ihr tag sagt so schnell gar nicht dass
er niemals verbinden so schnell wie die
zeit läuft ende schlagen oh mein gott
händisch lang bin ich am einfachsten von
allem aber der rest bei der
geschwindigkeit ist nochmals schneller
wollt ihr mich verarschen wolfram peek
at wo ist die denn da oben rechts ist
sie habe einen punktestand von 190
damals geschenkt 15 münchen bekommen
wiederhole okay okay dass das dass das
[Musik]
frustriert was gut
das spiel ist wirklich übel das was ihr
vom video meine damen und herren wenn
euch das spiel gefallen hat und ihr das
eventuell nochmal wollt wo ich ein neues
areal spiele oder so dann lasst manfred
leitner bevor ich jetzt allerdings die
end karten machen und euch sagen dass
ihr meinen kanal abonnieren könnt und
euch noch ein video eine blende löse ich
noch eben das gewinnspiel auf von dem
iphone
ich suche gerade den gewinner vom iphone
7 gewinnspiel raus allerdings spart
diese website die ganze zeit ab weil
oder dem video halt einfach ihn wie eine
million kommentare sind hier oben steht
leiding 196.000 kommend auf 1963 pages
aber der schon bei page 2022 und
kommentar 200.000 das ist eigentlich
erst ein fünftel oder ein sechstel oder
wieso es wäre ja alles auch gar kein
problem wenn die website auch vernünftig
laufen will allerdings muss sich alle 20
sekunden auswählen ja mach noch weiter
jahre drei kennst und keine ahnung was
weil es einfach so viele kommentare sind
deswegen werde ich jetzt einfach mal
internet ausstellen und dann läuft er
noch ein bisschen weiter und dann wird
er irgendwann stoppen und der kommentare
hat gewonnen ich habe jetzt meinen
wählern hier oben deaktiviert er zeigt
mir jetzt hier an die da diese komische
sache wohl sonst marie zwei gedrückt
habe aber jetzt würde ich einfach mal
auf cancel und jetzt hat ja toll
der kreis hat geworden eigentlich sollte
man auch schreiben wo man erreicht
werden kann also den instagram namen
oder irgendwie so aber konnte jetzt auch
seinen namen einfach draufklicken also
hier gut ich hab dich gefunden als er
sogar ein paar ab laut selbst also ich
werde ich jetzt irgendwie anschreiben
also checkt demnächst legen wie weil sie
nicht dein youtube ports erinnern oder
wir möchten schreiben werde wir gerade
schon gesehen hat habe ich das ganze
eine andere kulisse aufgenommen also ich
hab das schon vorgestern zu hause
aufgenommen weil mein laptop da die
ganze durchgelaufen ist mit den ganzen
kommentaren aber auf jeden fall an dich
fcn ich weiß ganz genau wie du siehst
aber auf jeden fall herzlichen
glückwunsch ich hab dich angeschrieben
hier findet hier ein smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr darauf klickt könnte meinen
kanal abonnieren das ist kostenlos
verpasst keine videos mehr und man
bieten
es ist cool und hier findet irgendein
anderes video eingeblendet ist bestimmt
mega beschissen aber klicks doch trotz
machen man was macht ihr sonst jetzt